[Music]
binance the largest crypto exchange in
the world and it's billionaire founder
cz they are investing 200 million
dollars in forbes now this isn't exactly
what you would expect a crypto exchange
is buying a massive amount of equity in
a traditional publisher cz tweeted out
today and said invest in both new and
old and bridge them with crypto finance
taking a 200 million dollar stake in
forbes now we actually break down what
are these two businesses they couldn't
be more different forbes is a 104 year
old magazine and digital publisher
there's 150 million people through
content and events finance though was
just founded in 2017 it's a relatively
young company but it is the world's
largest crypto exchange by trading
volume and when you bring these together
what you can see is that binance it's
atop the list of the top cryptocurrency
spot exchanges they got volume they've
got 29 million weekly visitors and they
have 1600 markets that they allow
trading in ultimately binance ncz
believe that forbes with all that
content generation all those events the
150 million people they reach they can
supercharge the crypto industry bringing
together bitcoin cryptocurrencies web 3
and go ahead and melt it together with
forbes that's why this 200 million
dollar investment's happening now many
people don't realize that forbes is
actually merging with a spec there was
400 million dollars announced earlier
last year now finance is going to step
in and they're going to take out 200 of
the 400 million dollars half of the
money being invested is going to come
from finance it's a very very big deal
we've got this quote here from somebody
who according to knowledge of binance's
strategy said this is the first time in
a marketplace that is really high
potential when it comes to adoption of
web3 based tools our industry has seen a
ton of growth and we think you'd have to
be a fool not to position yourself in
those sectors that are ripe for
infrastructure investment ultimately i
think that we are going to see many more
things like this it's a company in the
crypto industry that is dominant that
has absolutely got a great position
they've got a lot of cash and they're
going to inject that cash into a
traditional business they're going to
try to modernize it they're going to try
to bring web 3 to the legacy world
expect more deals like this expect a lot
more cash to be flowing from crypto into
other businesses whether they're buying
content publishers they're buying banks
they're buying financial institutions or
they're simply buying your favorite
company the crypto companies have tons
of cash the founders are incredibly
ambitious
and i think that we're just getting
warmed up